tell me some alternative forms of energy
well there's wind power which at 4.3% is
the fifth largest source of electricity
in the United States
excellent I'm gonna put downwind yeah I
was also gonna say wind but since Mike
said wind I'm gonna just say who wind
hey I'll put that wind again professor
rich why do we have to have class in
this janitor's closet anyway because the
Dean put us on probation because of that
narc wait someone's coming boy
it's sure good to not be teaching
anymore just a big stupid loser now yeah
you're just gone I kinda wish you were
dead right now I just farted
I'm professor rich expert in science
these are my devoted students together
with the aid of harmless drugs we
explore Sciences greatest hypothetical
questions
hey this wasn't here before the teen
already gave this class away to
Professor Lehman from Egypt ology I wish
they leave - alone
pretty good right it's not fair but
that's rich you don't deserve this past
husband you die those are kind words -
coming from you they mean very little
right now we're on probation and we can
still redeem ourselves but we have to
keep our noses clean that means no
vaping yeah let's get started with a
hypothetical what if martial arts could
be used to harness energy well I guess
it would really depend on like how much
energy we're talking if you were to
harness what amounts to the electricity
of a large city I estimate you probably
need about a hundred thousand martial
artists kick in round the clock so it
could work yeah wait somebody's coming
gosh I was just with you instead
of staying up all night I roamed the
streets and then when the Sun came up I
had an idea
solar energy hello
zan yes that's right yes I am professor
rich nice to meet you
I understand you're an expert in energy
my company uses thousands of mirrors to
reflect light and what if I get a little
closer that would be great ok great I
had this down on my list of questions
why why what I just have why I have a
theory
what if alternative energy can be done
in a human way like through some kind of
motion you're talking about like a human
hamster wheel kind of a gerbil wheel you
know most of the issues with that are
moral or not scientific or technical in
nature this is the Sun right so as you
describe the Sun starts heat up and then
it creates energy now in human form
we're moving about we're a whirling
dervish of motion and ah this is a Ninja
Warrior or some kind of martial artists
and he's moving so could a karate chop I
charge my iPhone could a nice
well-placed kick boil some water if you
had enough of them I could imagine you
could attach some kind of power
generation device you know excuse me
your old trusty pager I've got to go and
scene okay stop some 5.7 kilowatts
you've officially lit this bulb for 10
seconds well how clever of you to return
to your old classroom oh no wait I met
stupid consider all of you on double
probation but I've got more important
classes to go to you should have thought
of that before you join these reprobates
I don't any real estate nice try mrs.
Pearson you've been in this class for
eight months all of you have made a
bismal mistake siding with this before
normals he could cost you your futures
energy martial arts nerve you know what
and another thing you
hi I'm here on the set of the new Woody
Allen film bananas - to meet with
legendary stunt coordinator Stephen ho
Stephen hi hi hi professor rich pleasure
we're trying to harness energy from
karate is that possible for what
purposes we we've attached electrodes to
our arms in order to light up the room
so we need to use the most expendable
energy for karate as possible so you
want people to do karate to create
energy yes I was just wondering what
moves in karate are probably give you
the most energy would you like to try
the hitting I'm EFT and don't
worry professor rich you one of us will
take the blame for you hell no we're all
gonna die I wish I had tater with me
what's tater your Earline shirt no my
dog do you have a dog cats are clearly
the best animal pen please
Wow
works it really works Clark reinstated
next one that was a mad possum what if
II did not equal MC squared well I guess
that would make it two times that I
don't give a
I don't know professor I mean it's a
pretty ironclad theory countless
scientists come on people
open up your minds not that way